nous emmener à l'autre bout du monde en
australie
et quand la présentation me permettra je
vous montrais un oiseau est ce que vous
connaissez cet oiseau au fait cet oiseau
là une particularité c'est que déjà il
est polygame comme ça c'est quand même
assez intéressant ensuite la deuxième
chose c'est qui
étant donné qu'il a pas mal de conquêtes
il doit avoir une cote technique de dar
es assez particulière il fait des ni
déni les plus beau possible pour charmer
ses conquêtes et donc si vous voulez
lire
il récupère tout ce qu'ils trouvent
autour de lui pour pour faire des nids
auparavant et utilisaient des des fleurs
des fruits des coquillages ça se passait
très bien
maintenant ils récupèrent des bouchons
des pinces à linge des des pailles en
plastique ça se passe encore mieux
paradoxalement l'idée c'est de se dire
que comme cet oiseau on peut faire en
sorte de retourner les contraintes sur
ce qui nous entoure et de les
transformer en opportunité voilà un
petit peu ce que ce que donne ce fameuse
ses réalisations au niveau d'une en gros
merci à piquer notre économie considérée
tout ça tout ce qui nous entoure comme
des ressources faire disparaître la
notion de déchet on appelle ça
l'économie circulaire l'économie
circulaire
c'est peut-être une des réponses à nos
nombreux problèmes qu'on est en train
d'affronter réchauffement climatique
disparition des ressources disparition
de la biodiversité et j'en passe le
souci c'est qu'actuellement
vous imaginez bien qu'on n'est pas du
tout dans un système comme ça
aujourd'hui on est dans un système
linéaire c'est à dire que on se rend de
plus en plus compte qu'on est sur une
planète aux ressources limitées et donc
d'un côté on utilise les ressources
toutes les matières premières et d'un
autre côté
on a de plus en plus de déchets par
exemple
enfin voilà aujourd'hui en fait mon
objectif c'est de vous dire comment on
fait pour changer de paradigme parce que
la bonne nouvelle c'est que finalement
on a tous une marge de manoeuvre pour
faire en sorte de changer de paradigme
et d'activer l'économie circulaire
aujourd'hui vous imaginez bien qu'on est
assez loin de ce paradigme en france par
exemple il ya seulement 20 à 30 % des
déchets qui sont véritablement valorisé
90% des choses que l'on achète sont
jetés dans les six mois donc vous
imaginez bien qui a une certaine marge
de progression est donc si vous voulez
l'objectif c'est de se sortir de ce
paradigme et donc il ya trois aspects
finalement qui font que on est dans un
espace à une économie qui partent un
petit peu en live
l'idée c'est qu'à trois aspects
fondamentaux sur lesquels on peut
changer et qu'on a qu'on peut considérer
comme des constats le premier c'est que
l'économie est complètement bloquée sur
un principe c'est à dire le plus le plus
vite possible la chose la moins chère on
pressent tous les éléments de la chaîne
pour faire en sorte qu'on apprenait le
produit tout de suite et qu'on s'en
débarrasse juste après l'exemple du rhin
à plaza c'est plus de 1000 morts c'est
l'exemple même de ce principe qui nous
ramène à avoir tout de suite les choses
au moins cher possible
le deuxième aspect c'est que la france
nice illustre particulièrement bien ce
point c'est que nos entreprises nos
organisations fonctionnent en silo les
financiers pensent à la finance
businessman pense au business les
ingénieurs pensent à la dernière techno
les écologistes pensent à
l'environnement malheureusement on s'en
rend bien compte les organisations sont
moins en moins en mesure de répondre aux
problématiques de façon pertinente
pourtant chacun on a en mesure enfin une
partie de la réponse
au fond de vous et donc l'idée c'est de
faire appel finalement un petit peu plus
à la coopération
on est tous sur le même bateau on est
tous sur la même planète
et on se rend bien compte que si on rame
dans des sens différents
à court moyen long terme on va pas très
loin là l'objectif c'est justement
casser ces silos également ensuite
troisième constat c'est qu'on parle
toujours du principe que les entreprises
quelles qu'elles soient
même nous en tant qu'être humain on a
des impacts négatifs sur l'environnement
sur la nature il faut vraiment sortir de
ce paradigme parce que finalement on se
rend compte que l'objectif avait enfin
avec ses impacts finalement on essaie de
réduire les impacts négatifs mais l'idée
c'est quand on essaie de me polluer ou
polluer moins
piller ou billets - ça reste négatif
quand on regarde d'un point de vue plus
global et donc l'idée c'est de se dire
non on peut penser des business models
façon à ce qu'on ait des impacts
positifs des impacts positifs sur
l'économie la société l'environnement
c'est juste une question de conception
de design des business models là c'est
un exemple qui est particulièrement
illustratif de ce principe interface qui
est un des leaders mondiaux des
solutions de revêtements de sol en 2004
en 2014 en fait plus d'un milliard de
chiffre d'affaires
et ça c'est un de leurs derniers
produits en fait pour lutter contre le
phénomène de pêche fantôme aux
philippines qui ravagent des écosystèmes
marins e-bay des pêcheurs philippins
pour récupérer ses filets et à partir de
ces filets en nylon
il leur fabrique leurs propres produits
donc vous imaginez
d'un côté multiplié les sources de
revenus pour les pêcheurs auraient
génère un écosystème marin qui est qui
d'une richesse incroyable
et en plus ils recréent des idées
des business incroyable les impacts
positifs sont nombreux tout comme les
impacts tout comme les sources de
revenus qu'on soit dès le début du
lancement d'un produit un service on
peut concevoir des business models de
façon à les rendre positif du début à la
fin et donc l'idée c'est de se dire
finalement si on changeait les règles
mais si on changeait même les règles du
jeu si on jouait vraiment finalement
parce que on se rend bien compte que
quand on joue
eh ben on arrive vraiment à comprendre
le miracle de la coopération
c'est à dire que encore une fois chacun
de vous vous avez une part de la
solution est donc quand on mobilise
certains sur vos travers leur expérience
leur savoir et qu'on additionne tout ça
finalement
ma un plus un égale 3 et donc à travers
le jeu les gens comprennent qu'on que la
coopération est nettement plus
intéressante dans la coopération
il y en a pour tout le monde c'est pas
juste comme dans la concurrence on
écrase les autres etc
on multiplie les créations de valeur et
surtout on multiplie en la création de
valeur on distribue de façon beaucoup
plus cohérente
ensuite quand on joue finalement on met
tous les artefacts à disposition pour
faire en sorte de gagner et donc on
essaie d'être le plus créatif possible
le plus impactant possible et donc on
teste on avance et c est ça c'était la
meilleure façon de changer d'entreprise
aujourd'hui
arrêtons de faire des études testons
fait
faisons en sorte de faire bouger les
choses et de dire petit étape étape par
étape
ensuite quand on joue là finalement on
s'occupe de tous les aspects et on prend
conscience de la portée de nos choix
d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire que on va
bien sûr prendre en compte le business
mais on va aussi prendre sur un même
pied
la technologie utilisée mais aussi
l'humain est ce que ces pratiques
est-ce que c'est agréable est ce que
c'est éthique mais aussi prendre en
compte la nature la nature n'est pas une
contrainte la par nature on en fait
partie
et donc il faut prendre en compte tous
ces aspects là pour aller beaucoup plus
loin pour nos innovations et donc
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est de jouer
jouer parce que quand vous allez arriver
dans ces entreprises quand vous allez
lancer des dés boîte quand vous sortirez
de cette école eh bien il va falloir que
vous jouiez tous ensemble et donc à ce
propos je propose ce plateau de jeu qui
vous permettra d'imaginer les business
models de demain parce que l'idée sera
bien évidemment vous re créer des
opportunités économiques mais aussi de
faire du bien parce qu'on a vraiment
besoin de tous ensemble jouer pour
activer l'économie circulaire jouer tout
simplement parce qu'on a besoin de
changer de paradigme
on a besoin de jouer pour changer et
cette notion de déchets qui finalement
est à l'origine de beaucoup de problèmes
qui nous entoure et donc jouons pour
recréer des opportunités économiques
sociales et environnementales
merci à tous